cette année pas de visites guidées prévu
pour l'espace rambouillet le parc
restera exceptionnellement fermée pour
cause sa reprise par un gestionnaire
privé à la rentrée pour la dizaine de
salariés le temps passe et d'ordinaire
avec les visiteurs seraient occupés
cette année par l'entretien des lieux et
le bien-être des animaux
[Musique]
notre objectif c'est de s'occuper des
animaux du bien-être des animaux doit
les alimenter de suivre le bon état de
la forêt des arbres
des clôtures parce que ça parte clos
donc il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient pas
de trou dans le grillage si c'est le cas
il faut réparer l'espace rambouillet
regorge d'espèces 4 en forêt sauvage
avec les daims les sangliers les
chevreuils et les serres mais aussi une
quarantaine d'espèces de rapaces des
oiseaux qui chaque année volts en
présentation devant un public malgré la
fermeture pas question de les priver
d'exercice
[Musique]
les ressortir de volières on va les
remettre en condition de voir qu'on va
les faire voler mais là ce sera pour
nous quand entre nous aura pas de
visiteurs donc on prendra le temps de
faire les choses et de laisser voler
leurs aises l'espace rambouillet
accueille également un centre de soins
de la faune sauvage toute l'année les
particuliers peuvent y déposer les
oiseaux trouvé en détresse 250 oiseaux
ont été reçus en 2021 objectif les
soigner et les relâcher dans la
vétérinaire qui vient plusieurs fois par
semaine qui fait partie de l'équipe
c qui est responsable du centre de soins
donc là c'est une petite buse variable
qui a été trouvé sur l'autoroute
par un particulier
donc là certainement eu un choc avec un
poids lourd
[Musique]
est et rhône a été un peu affaibli donc
là l'objectif c'est de remettre
la grassouillette la cession du parc
animalier devrait se faire à l'été 2022
c'est une qualité de vie qu'on prend
c'est important c'est pour ça pour
préserver ce parc là j'espère qu'il va
être repris par quelqu'un de bien la
reprise avec le nouveau concessionnaire
devrait avoir lieu en septembre